whatever you think about whether there
are actual ghosts in A Haunting in
Venice the characters are clearly
haunted in other ways by War by Love by
failure here's how their tragedies all
tie together warning spoilers ahead
The Haunting in Venice takes place in
the fall of 1947 as the Italian city of
canals undertakes a much needed period
of peace and healing following the end
of World War II I retired her cure plaro
enjoys a compass of walks pastries and
perfectly prepared eggs with seemingly
no interest in being a detective anymore
that is until his old acquaintance
mystery writes to ariadne Oliver
approaches him with a proposition
ariadne has been invited to Seance at a
local Palazzo the world famous medium
Joyce Reynolds has been hired to contact
the spirit of the late Alicia Drake a
young woman who seemingly killed herself
after a prolonged period of mental
illness Alicia's mother Rowena a
housekeeper Olga Family Doctor Leslie
Ferrier and Alicia's ex-fiance Maxim
Gerrard are among the others in
attendance upon ariadne's request quarro
attends a seance to try and prove that
Reynolds is a fake spot the car and I
can't he identifies some tricks in her
act but things get more serious when the
medium is thrown from the balcony and
impaled on a statue below as a storm
besieges a palazzo farro locks the gates
and begins to investigate as he too
begins to see ghosts in a supposedly
cursed house he struggles to identify
the truth
as pyro investigates the deaths of Drake
and Reynolds he makes a number of
shocking discoveries he interviews the
medium's assistants half-siblings
Nicholas and Desdemona Holland he also
speaks with Dr Ferrier who suffers from
debilitating PTSD not his creepy son
Leopold Dr Ferrier falls into a violent
episode that is subsequently logged in
the palazzo's nearly soundproof music
room for the supposed safety of all
involved farro deduces that ariadne was
actually in cahoots with Miss Reynolds
the whole time along with Barro's
bodyguard bitale portfolio who's
revealed to be the police officer who
found Alicia's body ariadne helped Miss
Reynolds and her assistance rig all the
tricks for the Seance her goal was to
stump Farrow and make him admit to the
medium's Palace just admit that you are
up against something bigger than you
ariadne was planning to write a hit book
about Reynolds to return to the top of
the literary establishment as praro
interrogates a redne Dr Ferrier is found
dead the legend of the palazzos says
that it's haunted by the ghosts of
Orphan children who were killed by
brutal doctors and nurses some assume
that Dr ferrier's Death has proof of the
supernatural but praro has another
explanation he reveals that The Grieving
mother Rowena Drake is actually the one
responsible for the whole bloody affair
Alicia Drake suffered from a
psychological illness after being dumped
by Maxine she claimed to see ghosts in
the house but in reality her Affliction
was nothing Supernatural jealous and
terrified of losing her daughter to her
husband Rowena caused a split and
concocted a plan to keep her daughter by
her side in perpetuity using a special
poison grown in her honey Garden she
kept Alicia sickly and Sedated by
spiking her tea when Olga volunteered to
watch Alicia for the night she
unknowingly gave her a fatal dose of the
drug to cover up her evil deed her
weiner threw her daughter off the
balcony and left the mark of the
children's Vendetta on her invoking the
supposed curse she may not have meant
for Alessia to die but she willingly
harmed her for weeks purely else of
jealousy and made it very easy for an
accident to happen she came back to tell
me that she was murdered Viro discovers
that Rowena is being blackmailed by
someone who knows her secret after the
Seance she kills Reynolds and changes
one of the clocks to give herself an
alibi she either suspects that meet is
the blackmailer or feels that a second
Seance will uncover the truth he has
eventually revealed that the medium was
running an entirely separate con the
black male of Rowena came from a much
less obvious place
praro briefly suspects that Dr ferriier
was blackmailing Rowena the woman he
loved but who never returned to his
affections his autopsy of Alessia should
have revealed that she died from Poison
not drowning but his actions were
malicious the doctors declarting mental
condition caused him to miss the obvious
or perhaps he was blinded by love that
said someone did notice the poisoning
ferrier's son Leopold the young boy was
the one black male in Rowena in a scheme
to provide for himself and his dad after
his father's death and the resolution of
the case the boy is taken in by Olga he
laments what happened but Poirot assures
him that it isn't his fault no child
should have to be a parent to their
parents and the scars of the war forced
him into an impossible position rather
than keep the remaining blackmail money
Leopold and Olga decide to give it to
Nicholas and Desdemona so that they can
travel to Saint Louis as is their dream
Farrow explains that the death of Dr
Ferrier was an elaborate manipulation
orchestrated by Rowena Drake the
combination of intense PTSD and
unrequited love for arena leaves a
doctor in a highly vulnerable state and
she convinces him over the Inner Health
telephone to kill himself making it look
like a supernatural event there are a
few different reasons why she does this
Rowena is clearly paranoid about her
blackmailer and she may think it's the
doctor since he was the one who
performed the autopsy or maybe she fears
that he will return to his nose after
all of the commotion and the Nerf the
truth regardless his isolated death
makes a strong case for the ghost being
real which would theoretically absolve
Arena of culpability the doctor's death
is perhaps the saddest in the whole film
Leopold tries so hard to care for his
father in a well that's utterly
unprepared to deal with the Mental
effects of the war when he sees him
lying Dead all he can say is why did he
have to be alone
there we add the Oliver isn't guilty of
murder but pyro does catch her in a
devious scheme she tries to use him as a
tool in her literary comeback even
bringing his bodyguard into the plan to
help make Reynolds seem legit at the
beginning of the movie she tells praro
that her last three books have been
critically planned she also claims to be
responsible for making the detective
famous in the first place by publicizing
an early case of his she argues then
that she has every right to use him the
two don't exactly part on the best of
terms but Poirot doesn't seem to hold a
grudge against her ariadne is a Mainstay
of Agatha Christie's fiction and
frequently served as a stand-in for the
author herself her Arc in a haunting in
Venice is a good deal different from a
role in the book the film is based on
Halloween party but there is an
interesting connection the novel
received generally negative reviews upon
release and was written off by many as
proof that Christie was past her prime
it's interesting to see ariadne dealing
with a similar dilemma in a haunting in
Venice
after Poirot catches Rowena in her lies
she confronts him on a balcony as the
storm rages quarro catches a glimpse of
what appears to be a ghost in the
lightning it's the shape of Alicia
hanging in the air looming behind her
mother in the next moment Farina loses
her balance and plummets off the balcony
to her death the audience ampuaro are
left to wonder if she was blown off by
the wind or pushed by a spirit farro
discovers that his own hallucinations
around the house were caused by Rowena's
poisonous honey or were they Leopold
repeatedly says that he talks to the
ghosts of children in the Palazzo some
of them he claims are even his friends
he has no reason to think that Alicia's
death was Supernatural but he insists
that the haunting is real his poor Rose
still affected by the honey when he sees
Rowena 4 or does he actually see a ghost
on the balcony the secret basement of
the Palazzo confirms the evil deeds and
numerous deaths that took place there
even puero can't explain the whole thing
someone else is in this house Faro
leaves the Palazzo the next morning a
seemingly changed man he has a new
passion for detective work and
immediately returns to it accepting a
case that was proposed to him in the
opening scene why does a man so firmly
in retirement lead back to his old job
after his experience of the Palazzo
maybe it's because this particular brush
for death makes him re-examine how he
wants to live at the beginning of the
film huaro openly admits that he has no
friends and it's hard to imagine that
Solitude is always a good thing for him
Reynolds tells him at one point we know
they're dead too well I think they have
our own powers as a medium are left
ambiguous Juarez seem to take a
statement to Heart his line of work is
not a happy one but it is a calling and
he returns to it with renewed Vigor he
seems decidedly driven to start actively
living again
a home to convenience is a murder
mystery and a ghost story but it's also
about the aftermath of World War II by
moving Halloween party from its original
English setting to Italy in 1947
director and starred Kenneth Branagh and
screenwriter Michael Green be oriented
to focus Dr Ferrier suffers because of
the things he saw in the war and this
psychological wound causes him to
misdiagnose Alicia's cause of death
because of his PTSD his son is forced to
grow up extraordinarily quickly and
become the adult in the family this
pushes him to make the questionable
decision of blackmailing Rowena instead
of coming forward with evidence against
her with his father unable to work what
choice does he have the Holland half
siblings are also scarred by the war
they want to go to Saint Louis because
they saw it in a movie that the American
soldiers who saved their lives show them
their whole conception of a happy life
is determined by their horrific
experiences in Warzone Europe they're a
bigger ghosts that haunt the story
Beyond those said to be in the Palazzo
Venice Italy in the World At Large are
trying to pull themselves together
rather after an unfathomable amount of
violence
the Hollywood labor union strikes
prohibit writers and actors from
marketing upcoming projects so there
hasn't been much promotion from the cast
and crew of a haunting in Venice but
back in April 2023 before either strike
up a gun Kenneth Branagh did speak with
The Hollywood Reporter about the film he
couldn't say much about the movie's
ending and spoil the surprises but
Branagh did suggest some interesting
things about potential sequels when
asked if it faced Studio pressure to
unite his Bravo films under a single
franchise title for marketing Rana said
he hadn't thus far his phrasing suggests
that the director and stars plans for
even more Agatha Christie Mysteries
which he seemed to confirm later on
saying the movies are what they are and
if it evolves in a different way we'll
cross those particular Bridges when we
come to them but so far I've just been
left to go on with the titles as they
are that certainly leaves the door wide
open for more Faro cases on the big
screen provided a haunting in Venice
performs well enough to justify them
Branagh isn't the only one who sounds
optimistic about more pyro Mysteries
coming down the line prior to the
release of a haunting in Venice
executive producer James Pritchard spoke
with total film about the possibility of
more sequels set in Agatha Christie's
mystery Universe saying if Ken Branagh
wants to do more and Michael Green wants
to write more we'll certainly do another
there's a lot of material still to go so
we're not going to run out of
inspiration with Christy's whole Library
available for potential adaptation
Granite series could indeed go on for as
long as he wants provided the box office
returns are there however Pritchard who
is Christie's great grandson and CEO of
her literary estate emphasized that it's
also important to keep things fresh
saying if we are going to continue to
make these films we can't do the same
thing over and over a haunting in Venice
is definitely a bit of a shift from
murder on the Orient Express and Death
on the Nile throwing the mystery more
into the supernatural Thriller category
which is pretty exciting because it
involves him and us being scared it
would also be great to see Tina Fey
returners ariadne Oliver if audiences
respond well to the film and just many
changes to Christie's work future
sequels could get even more creative